[Music]
anybody ever heard of vladimir the
cannibal he a people
well done thank you yeah i'm a history
buff yeah
cannibals in his name so he kind of gave
it away is he an ancient warrior
if my ancient is still alive uh yeah
always recently are you thinking about
like hannibal the cannibal i'm thinking
about you know they're like oh alexander
the great i'm like oh his this guy was
like from the 1600s because he got like
a the in his description he ate his
enemies and stuff fluffy shirt and a
nice coat a piece of [ __ ]
i guess he's like i don't know megan's
stallion's kind of cool v that's
different that's megan v stallion but
she's great i'm a big fan so vladimir
i always get these names crazy
nikolayevich nikolayev sounds like a
wrestler it's kind of redundant age 63
was convicted of killing two men in 97
in
novocs
in russia sounds like a nuclear power
plant thank you
although initially handed the death
penalty
nikolayev had his sentence commuted to
life behind bars after the country
abolished the death penalty my god dude
so he's just randomly in that pocket
during during a change in the uh in the
law would it turn non-soviet yeah but he
took part in a national geographic
documentary titled
inside russia's toughest prisons oh
those are tough in which he spoke about
eating one of his victims holy [ __ ] a
person can't be that tough if he's still
alive in it yeah that's true he's
surviving but maybe because he scared
everybody maybe he's really likable and
everyone likes them well the inmates
like him he's eating people yeah
that's how he survived
why is it a lot because he's eating
everybody else only living prisoner and
everyone else dies everyone else is
hungry he didn't do that in prison did
he no no why are you guys gonna go so
dark what if he's just like a really fun
cool guy everyone likes hey vlad
dude vlad's the funny guy on that i'm a
seller oh you're talking like uh like uh
noho hank and barry oh my god he's great
right he's like obvi he's hard he's
tough but he's also very nice yeah he's
great he just wants out he wants a life
too you know he wants to experience he's
misunderstood so speaking while inside
the notorious kasich's dolphin prison
where he was transferred in 2001
nikolayev said he had no intention of
eating human flesh when he carried out
the murder but was tempted to try it
while dismembering his victim's corpse
you know i know what he feels like yeah
god because like i was so [ __ ] hungry
during lunch right and then um like
today
it was during lunch
we were filming
we were we were filming at the community
college and i was playing a student
and i had an anatomy book so i was like
man [ __ ] flipping pages were the
titties that [ __ ] you know cause like
they always show obviously
go straight to the titties no titties
female reproductive
all these muscle fibers
and i was like you know what that arm
looks kind of good like it kind of looks
like steak right now and i was like see
this is how cannibalism starts
you're curious it's a curious cannibal
that's how it starts all muscle fibers
look the same
i'm i'm not i don't discriminate red
meat purple meat whatever me human it
looks the same when it's underneath
friends me same thing exactly
but then when you're looking at it in an
anatomy book and you just it's like
sectioned off you're like yo that looks
like kind of a [ __ ] that looks like
oxtail right now like right there that
[ __ ] spine with a little bit of meat
that looks like oxtail yeah once i get
rid of the human hair and the teeth
thing well they're not they don't show
this that it's the muscle fiber part
it's just that and in the dried part
that looks like beef jerky so i was like
man i don't want to do this i'm getting
too hungry looking at human so if they
so if they came out with you know how
they have lab meat where they just make
meat
not using an animal they just create it
that's gross would you
i agree i agree i'm a jaundice i'm i'm
going to say if they if they were
manufacturing like
lab meat that's human meat
would you try it only if it's dick i'm
just kidding i don't know
um if i won't get sick yeah you won't
get yeah i won't get sick if it's
manufactured i mean if i won't get sick
i would try that too yeah if i won't get
sick if i won't be sick but you're gonna
eat a human man if someone gets sick i
would try that too but uh hey you're
going to do it i don't want to be if i
will get sick yeah i don't want to get
sick would you eat a human flavored
gummy i'd eat a human before i eat a dog
but i heard that people cannibalism and
people that eat human they get sick
like
oh they get sick from it yeah i heard
that so yeah in the mind even if they
properly cook it i know a guy that
actually ate a ate a person what do you
say
you got sick how do you know a guy who
actually ate a pizza oh uh he's my
friend's uncle and he goes whoa yeah so
he's like in the vietnam he goes
man we got lost in the jungle
and then you know uh we got attacked and
then
for so many days we don't even know
where to go you know so hungry
and then um my friend died
and then we
have no food for so many times you do
the math for so many times you do the
math
we decide
okay we have to cook him
i was like you couldn't find a banana no
food you couldn't find a [ __ ] coconut
it's a jungle no there's nothing man i
eat a tarantula before i eat a [ __ ]
human
but what ended up happening is they
didn't want to eat his like body and his
like parts so they opened up
and they said i got the lever and we
we wanted the most unhuman pot and then
we chop it up we fry it and we eat it
unhuman part and i was like did you eat
till you were full and he goes i
couldn't do it man i took one bite and i
was already full
i was like damn
yeah so they got they all chopped up his
liver and all they all took like
different but no one could actually like
eat a lot of it but they just ate like
well the organs have more nutrients than
the meat anyway how did they have
everything else he's like we don't have
food but i took out my air fryer
one hour
i love this guy though his name was
uncle ricky and he would tell us crazy
he was he would he would just be like
man the wall it was so scary sometime i
get a soul nightmare you know and i wake
up in the morning i'm choking my wife
i'm blessed
oh [ __ ] damn some wolverine [ __ ]
bring that fool on the show yeah i'll
try to find him no you know what i'll
try to find him he was one of the
craziest storytellers and then so he's
like he's not really my friend's uncle
but you know how in asian culture you
call everybody uncle yeah but um him
and my friend's dad became best friends
in a refugee camp
because then and then we so we and then
they like i forgot what we were watching
but we were watching some kind of
vietnamese movie about the war and then
these guys i think they went to hong
kong or something
and it was their first time like being
able to like explore a city outside of
vietnam and they were holding hands
everywhere and you know like us being
like
we made fun of everything that was gay
in in the early 2000s right so me and my
friend was dying during the whole
montage of them running around holding
hands looking at all the shops and we
were dying and [ __ ] crying right you
guys kiss already and then and then
uncle ricky was there and he was like
you know in the vietnam when your best
friend you hold hands everywhere and he
was getting mad like he goes that's
normal and i was like damn dude okay
uncle richard hey that is that is normal
when i was a kid i remember going to
vietnam and like people would hold hands
like that or an asian in general a lot
of a lot of countries do they're yeah
they'll hold hands with their friends
yeah
yeah and i thought i was like oh is
everybody just gay here and it's like no
best friends will just hold hands like
that and i was like that's wild yeah it
goes when you have a best friend you
just hold hands everywhere some middle
middle eastern countries do that yeah
and i just pictured this dude like
fighting war
and then in the in the middle of it he's
like holding hands with this
soldier like homie and just walking
around town and i'm just like oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i can only eat the liver of a man i hold
his hand with i know that's crazy the
[ __ ] that he told me dude i was like
dude that is crazy to get a first-hand
like account of eating humans well yeah
so this guy
it's actually pretty chilling what this
guy gets into and the way he starts
talking about because uh um it's
in a chilling way very human the way he
thinks about it or maybe not human i
guess maybe i'm dark i don't know he
says talking about the murder he says i
was coming home from a party a little
drunk and next to the door of my
building another guy also drunk asked me
for a light
we started arguing and got into a fight
he hit me and i hit him and it turned
out he died
in the chilling clip he goes on what was
i to do i dragged him into the bathroom
undressed him and started cutting him
apart
after cutting the man's head and limbs
nicholas nikoi nicole
gave a laugh and said he then felt the
urge to try him
wow i cut off a piece of meat from his
thigh and boiled it
he said
he said i tried it didn't like it so i
chopped it up and fried it in a frying
pan so he tried it again it's because he
boiled it my guy like of course he's all
like
oh even more horrifically
he then
gave some of the flesh to an unwitting
acquaintance who took it home and fed it
to his children and wife
with none of them knowing where the meat
had
originated he said he took it home and
gave it to his wife she made dumplings
with it she had some herself and fed
some to her children they didn't know
what it was
then nikolayev was accused of selling
around five kilograms of human flesh at
an open market claiming it was kangaroo
oh selling it that's kind of a really
smart way to get rid of it because
they're like i don't even know what this
is he was eventually caught after a
woman noted the unusual taste and took
it to a doctor for examination where it
was discovered what a [ __ ] snitch
dude
what a [ __ ] rat
this is a very weird
he's not a cannibalism but she's a
[ __ ] snitch that's what happened i
just can't believe a guy like this would
be candidate for rehabilitation
that's hilarious i know well he's he's
he's just not so much candid for
rehabilitation but it's just now that
they don't no longer have the death
penalty it's just life behind bars for
the rest of his life i'm kind of on the
side actually that guy should have been
talking [ __ ] dude she should have just
got it it was just a drunken like
accident yeah
brawl killed the guy and then got
curious as he was dismembering him he
got lemons and he made lemonade you know
what i mean he got human
human
human aids yeah that's what he did
[ __ ] crazy that he was selling this meat
to people maybe he was like oh i'm not
down to waste food
makes me feel like this wasn't the first
time he dismembered someone either yeah
for sure yeah like you go straight to
dismemberment yeah cause why do you do
that why don't you just throw it away
bury the guy i know like a normal person
oh that guy looks like a crazy nut but
he also just might be a russian dude too
i was always wondering like where they
where they still wore those jail hats
you know those jail hats like brother
where art thou yeah we always saw those
back in like hot dog on a stick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you